and as we're about to show you they
delivered big time well thank you team
excitement a moment of hype every year
what game words are they gonna announce
what trailer what new footage are they
gonna show us oh boy I sure love knowing
more about where I'm gonna spend $60 on
an overhyped product oh wait I can't
wait that's what a would say a man
of true culture true intellect
only cares about that snap that's right
cringe compilation everybody hooray
we're back from last year I feel like I
have barely recovered from last year my
god if you guys didn't know if you see
payback
I'm bum yes great game sadly we didn't
get as you know nothing's gonna be
Jessie's dammit but what a biggie we
begin with the e a cringe they delivered
wonderfully this year I must say
[Laughter]
oh why is this guy still hired I don't
want people to get fired every year he's
back I don't know why
[Laughter]
it's like that one guy at a party that
you just want I'm being too mean here
sorry like that one guy that you don't
want to talk to at a party that's just
what the vibe I'm getting I'm sure he's
a lovely fellow
it's just the vibe I'm getting all right
they had a wonderful little private
booth area that seemed really cool at
the EEA about nine months ago we said
what do we want to do and we were
thinking maybe we have a tent in the
corner for our access members we hand
out some water and then nine months pass
and it's a three-story structure with
the rooftop deck I mean certainly an
upgrade from a water tent that is for
sure so who are the folks that are gonna
be able to come into the access lounge
we're not exclusive so everyone is
welcome to come up to the access lounge
Wow Wow the XX loners yeah I sure wish I
could be allowed in the accidents you
know they paid thousands of dollars for
this oh my god
some games set out that we're gonna have
from our library the vaults we do have
water we also have power for your phone
I just I was just about to ask
I'm really glad they had that there's
trivia there's prices there's a ball pit
what yeah oh my god I didn't think they
would top they the lungs area but they
have a ball pit what yep damn yeah now I
really regret not flying to LA dami so
what's the deal with this belt so in my
Madden League when you win a
championship you got to show off your
championship so I got the belt so
everybody knows I'm the champ No
oh hello sometimes you have to stop and
smell the roses here at the flower wall
or just stop sorry sorry I'm just being
in bullying now this is all about
removing harassment from gaming oh
alright we get it feeling stop bullying
okay
let's move on to the actual EA
conference then we've got two new indie
games to share and then I'm gonna come
back towards the end of the show with
some of my favorite developers to give
you guys a nice meaty look at anthem and
of course yeah we got the Woo's for
anthem I'm into it you want it you wanna
do this with me you want it you wanna do
this with me why would she ask that I
don't get it give him give him a break
he needs to just enjoy the show as part
of our portrayal of the second world war
our portrayal of the Second World War
everybody it's his portrayal guys our
portray it's a portrait of history are
how we perceive history how we wanted
history to go down basically we want to
know more about our take on the Second
World War
your take on the second world why
there's no take you can't just change
battles am I crazy for thinking this I'm
not even like I don't even care about
the whole sex issue or whatever yeah I
realize I sound like one of those mole
rats
you will all go on an expanding journey
through the Second World War
no loot boxes no premium baths
it's kind of sad how that has to have a
chair to it you know you'll get
something I know a lot of you have been
asking for mm-hmm
it's Royale
it's people literally booing yes
everyone's another Royale
wow what a shocker the whole III is
basically just oh we're working on a
battle royale guys it's coming soon
please don't burn yourself out on for
tonight and I just happened to find a
mr. Vince Zampella here in the audience
Maryse mine what's going on Vince how
you feeling today I'm feeling great I
love this stuff
I love seeing new games I mean someone's
super excited about that event on PC
right yeah if I ever did a live thing I
will never make the audience chair cuz
it's just so painful if they don't I
mean someone's super excited about that
men on PC right yeah
amazing what a mat thank you so much
I was awesome any sauces I just came to
make mammoth tanks so I've done my job
any thoughts guys what do you think I
just want to get off stage and how
pleased you thought I would have noticed
that handshake let's move on to Sony's
conference yeah
[Music]
did no one play the DLC everyone seems
to make a big deal that they kissed it's
already happened if there's one thing to
be upset about is how Ellie looks so
ugly now Sony's press conference was
interesting it was about 2% games and
98% just music my favorite music
performance out of the sony III was the
flute guy it was beautiful
[Music]
Ubisoft's conference can be summarized
with one clip
[Music]
oh my god did you see the guy that fell
at the Ubisoft conference oh my god do
you think he got hurt I hope he didn't
get hurt from the most high performance
ever it's not a bad performance but the
audience isn't really there but then
finally the man the myth the legend Todd
Howard came out and he saved the whole
conference
Todd announced that the new Fallout game
is going to be an online game which
seems like a great idea
online games are hard they can have some
nasty issues I I read on the internet
that our games have had a few bugs I
read it on the internet so it's true I
read it on the Internet so it's true
okay so that was oh it's free three this
year so many games to be excited about
now for real I think it's fun to see at
least what new games are coming up but
there's always so much hype around these
games you know all these companies try
and make you excited they talk about the
games literally years before they're
even confirmed when they're gonna
actually come out I don't know how many
times I've been hyped for a game in the
past or it just turned out to be pretty
mediocre I mean it happens all the time
you you get sold the idea of a game and
not really a game and I don't really see
a point in and buying into the whole oh
my god that's so cool I oh my god I'm so
excited like playing the game where they
come out stop being so hype about things
it doesn't help anyone and that's it for
me for now let me know if you enjoyed
this video leave a like if you did hit
the bell button and I see you guys
tomorrow
that's right everybody's big surprise
I'm gonna make a video tomorrow as well
thank you everyone and I see you a great
now I didn't
my own cringe you're welcome everybody I
read it on the internet so it's true
[Music]